by the time they reach here they are
exhausted and vulnerable and to make
things worse they're not necessarily
safe
we've been told by multiple officials in
romania and poland that human
traffickers are at the borders taking
advantage of the ukrainian refugee
crisis luring women into slavery and
prostitution and taking children to
salon
it is an horrific twist on an already
dreadful situation
hello ukraine
romanian police have set up checkpoints
to stop suspicious cars around the
border areas
the traffickers aren't always men women
are often used because they tend to
raise less suspicion and are more likely
to be trusted by female refugees
a lot of the refugees arriving now don't
have family or friends to go to
elsewhere in europe and so in their
desperation just to get out for ukraine
alive they're willing to go with
complete strangers
what we know what we're told is
happening is that people are being
trapped on facebook
online
the other side
so by the time they arrive at the border
it's already too late
they've arranged to meet someone they
don't know really who that person is
but the officials can't do anything
about it
and they're already
victims to human trafficking
border patrol officials that we spoke to
in poland didn't want to go on camera
but confirmed to us that some human
traffickers had been arrested and they
were hunting for more
in romania there is now a campaign at
the border to warn refugees and help
them if they need it
it's women and children and they are
already very tired and vulnerable
and as you know romania is
famous for its trafficking problem and
we just try to come with a solution to
protect the children by protecting their
mothers and informing them about the
risk of human trafficking
[Music]
more than three million refugees have
now crossed from ukraine in a little
over three weeks
most of them women and children there is
no way of knowing how many of those have
been picked up by human traffickers
but it is happening
the war in ukraine is bringing out the
worst in humanity
in so many different ways
alastair bunker sky news
on the ukrainian border